Salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux !
Au cinéma, on adore les films catastrophes,
cataclysmes climatiques, déluges, invasions extraterrestres.
Tous les scénarios, ou plutôt scénarii, apocalyptiques existent.
Et pourtant, de véritables désastres
peuvent nous tomber sur la tête.
Vous aviez aimé ma précédente
vidéo "Top",
alors c'est reparti pour mon top 5 des catastrophes naturelles
qui peuvent vraiment se produire.
Première catastrophe : le Big One. Direction la Californie !
Il s'agit d'un séisme dont
vous avez sûrement déjà entendu parler.
C'est un tremblement de terre dévastateur
qui peut ravager la côte ouest
des États-Unis à tout moment.
Selon les prévisions des scientifiques,
ce séisme pourrait atteindre
une magnitude de 8,2 à 8,4.
Pour vous donner une idée,
le séisme survenu au Japon en 2011,
à l'origine du tsunami,
a atteint une magnitude de 9,1.
Selon les estimations,
dans le pire des cas, le Big One pourrait faire plus de 1800 morts
et 50000 blessés et il causerait
200 milliardsde dollars de dommages.
Il faut dire que la Californie est
une zone propice
aux phénomènes sismiques de grande ampleur.
Depuis la frontière
mexicaine jusqu'au nord de San Francisco.
Sous l'océan Pacifique s'étire la fameuse faille de San Andreas.
Elle sépare deux plaques tectoniques : la plaque océanique pacifique
et la plaque continentale Nord américaine.
La première coulisse le long de la seconde de quelques centimètres par an.
En surface,
ça ne se voit pas, mais dans le sous-sol,
les charges s'accumulent jusqu'au moment
ou les forces tectoniques
sont trop importantes et que le sol cède.
Le décrochage est alors très rapide,
et très violent et provoque un tremblement de terre.
Pour l'instant, les scientifiques
ne peuvent pas encore prédire les séismes avec précision.
Pour le Big One,
la question n'est pas de savoir où, mais quand il se produira.
Ce que l'on sait, c'est que la faille de San Andreas s'active tous les 150 ans environ.
À chaque fois, d'immenses secousses
frappent la côte ouest américaine.
Le dernier séisme de grande ampleur
qui s'est produit dans la région
a eu lieu en 1906.
Il a causé la mort d'au moins 3000 personnes.
Certains sismologues estiment
que le Big One aurait 62% de chance
de frapper San Francisco
dans les dix prochaines années.
Deuxième catastrophe
qui se produira un jour ou l'autre
l'éruption du Vésuve dans la baie de Naples.
Avec deux autres volcans italiens,
l'Etna en Sicile et le Stromboli
juste à côté, c'est l'un des volcans les plus actifs d'Europe.
C'est aussi l'un des plus surveillés
au monde et le premier à l'avoir été.
Ses éruptions sont imprévisibles et peuvent prendre plusieurs formes.
Elles peuvent être effusives ou explosives.
Les éruptions effusives sont caractérisées
par de grandes coulées de lave
très liquides.
La température de la roche en fusion
atteint plus de 1000 degrés.
Elles détruisent tout sur leur passage
mais laisse le temps
aux populations de fuir.
Les éruptions explosives
sont beaucoup plus dangereuses.
Sous l'effet de la pression,
le bouchon qui ferme le volcan explose
projetant dans l'atmosphère des gaz
et des cendres incandescentes qui ensuite
dévalent les pentes à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres par heure.
Ce sont les fameuses nuées ardentes.
L'éruption la plus célèbre
et la plus violente du Vésuve
remonte au 24 août de l'an 79.
Elle avait alors détruit toute la région
et enseveli les villes romaines
d'Herculanum et de Pompéi sous la cendre.
Mais ce n'est pas la seule éruption cataclysmique du Vésuve.
Après plusieurs siècles de silence,
le volcan s'est à nouveau activé en 1631.
L'éruption a tué 4000 personnes et fait d'importants dégâts dans un rayon de 500 kilomètres.
Au fil des années,
le volcan a connu une cinquantaine
d'éruptions plus ou moins importantes.
La dernière remonte à 1944.
Depuis, le Vésuve est endormi mais pas éteint.
Selon les scientifiques,
il devrait se réveiller un jour ou l'autre
et les conséquences
pourraient être dramatiques.
4 millions de personnes vivent aujourd'hui dans l'agglomération napolitaine.
Troisième catastrophe ! On continue
avec un danger venu de l'espace.
Mais non, il ne s'agit pas de la chute
d'une météorite.
Imaginez un black out durant
plusieurs semaines.
Plus d'électricité, plus de communication,
des villes renvoyées au Moyen Âge.
Eh bien, c'est ce qui pourrait nous arriver en cas de super tempête solaire.
Alors de quoi s'agit-il ?
Eh bien, le soleil émet
sans cesse des rayonnements.
Il y a la lumière,
bien sûr, qui nous éclaire.
Mais il y a aussi des rayonnements nocifs.
C'est le champ magnétique de notre planète
qui nous protège de ces radiations.
Le problème, c'est qu'il arrive
parfois,
suite à une perturbation à la surface du soleil,
qu'une grande quantité de rayonnements soit libérée.
C'est ce qu'on appelle une éruption solaire.
Elle se traduit visuellement par un flash
lumineux à la surface du soleil.
Attention, quand je dis visuellement,
on ne peut pas le voir à l'œil nu.
D'abord, on ne regarde jamais le soleil
sans un dispositif adapté.
Ce flash correspond aux rayons ultraviolets et aux rayons X
qui sont invisibles à l'œil nu.
Ces éruptions sont parfois
accompagnées de gigantesques
jets de matière dans l'espace.
On parle alors de tempête solaire
et lorsque la Terre se retrouve
sur leur trajectoire, elles subissent ce
que l'on appelle
un orage géomagnétique.
Les tempêtes solaires peuvent ainsi
perturber le champ magnétique
de notre planète, irradier nos satellites
et endommager les réseaux électriques.
Le 10 mars 1989, au Québec,
à cause d'une tempête solaire,
plus de 6 millions de personnes se sont ainsi retrouvées sans électricité pendant 9h.
Aujourd'hui,
en cas de super tempête solaire,
les infrastructures technologiques du
monde entier pourraient être paralysées.
Vous imaginez ?
Non seulement,
il n'y aurait plus d'électricité, mais plus de télévision, plus de radio.
On perdrait les signaux GPS.
On pourrait même subir une panne complète
du réseau Internet.
Évidemment, ce serait un peu compliqué pour regarder Epicurieux sur YouTube.
Au passage,
si ce sujet sur les tempêtes solaires
vous plait, n'hésitez pas à le signaler en commentaire.
J'y consacrerai une vidéo complète.
Quatre !
Un méga tsunami ! Pour évoquer cette catastrophe,
on repart aux États-Unis,
dans l'océan Pacifique.
C'est ce que l'on appelle l'Hilina Slump.
Il s'agit de l'effondrement d'un volcan
situé à Hawaï qui déclencherait un méga tsunami.
Selon certaines études, le mont
Kilauea, volcan le plus actif de Hawaï,
se déplace à une vitesse moyenne de dix centimètres par an.
Le volcan glisserait ainsi progressivement
vers l'océan Pacifique.
En cas d'effondrement,
il pourrait déverser environ 12000
kilomètres cubes de roche dans l'océan.
Le choc au moment de l'impact
pourrait alors générer un méga tsunami
atteignant la côte ouest de l'Amérique
du Nord.
Même Los Angeles, située à 4000 kilomètres
de Hawaï, pourrait alors être touchée.
Les tsunamis sont des vagues géantes
qui se produisent à cause d'un
tremblement de terre ou de l'éruption
d'un volcan sous marin.
Mais ils peuvent aussi se produire
lorsqu'une immense quantité de débris
tombent dans l'océan.
Ainsi, un éboulement colossal ou la chute
d'un astéroïde peut provoquer des vagues
atteignant des dizaines,
voire des centaines de mètres de hauteur.
Sur le territoire français,
le danger existe aussi à Mayotte,
précisément dans l'océan Indien.
Là bas, un volcan sous marin
a été découvert en 2019.
Son activité génère de nombreux séismes sur l'île.
Mais le plus grand risque,
c'est le glissement de terrain.
Celui-ci pourrait engendrer un tsunami.
Il y a déjà eu des antécédents de ce type dans le monde.
En 1958,
dans la baie de Lituya, en Alaska,
un tremblement de terre de magnitude 8,3
a provoqué un éboulement gigantesque. 30 millions de mètres
cubes de roches et de glace se sont
effondrés dans l'eau, provoquant une vague
qui, au contact de la côte, est remontée
jusqu'à une altitude de 520 mètres.
Cinquième et dernière catastrophe : l'éruption d'un super volcan.
Il se trouve au nord ouest des États-Unis,
dans le parc de Yellowstone.
Beaucoup de touristes
s'y rendent pour profiter des paysages
et assister notamment au spectacle des geysers.
Mais peu de gens, au final, savent que ce
parc se trouve sur un gigantesque volcan.
Il faut dire qu'il n'a
pas la silhouette classique d'un volcan.
Il ne ressemble pas au Vésuve
au contraire, il forme ce que l'on appelle
une caldera, une vaste dépression
de 65 kilomètres de large.
Caldera est d'ailleurs un nom d'origine
portugaise qui signifie chaudron.
Elle s'est formée, cette caldera, il y a près de 630 000 ans
à la suite d'une violente éruption volcanique.
L'énorme réservoir de magma,
qu'on appelle aussi chambre magmatique,
contient encore de la roche en fusion
qui pourrait provoquer
une nouvelle éruption.
Sur Terre,
il existe 20 super volcans comme le Yellowstone
et ce sont de véritables dangers
pour l'humanité.
En cas d'éruption massive,
ils peuvent rejeter des dizaines
de millions de tonnes de cendres
et de dioxyde de soufre dans l'atmosphère.
Ces nuages empêcheraient les rayons
du soleil de passer, provoquant
un hiver volcanique, c'est-à-dire une chute brutale
des températures pendant plusieurs mois,
voire des années.
Des pluies acides détruiraient également les sols et pollueraient les eaux.
Bref, un véritable cataclysme. Bon, pas de panique.
Les scientifiques estiment que les chances annuelles d'une éruption de ce type
sont de 1 sur 730000.
Ce n'est pas ce qui va m'empêcher
de dormir. Il y a bien pire en ce moment.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
C'est le meilleur soutien
que vous pouvez apporter à la chaîne.
Si certains sujets vous tiennent à cœur
et que vous souhaitez que je les traite
dans ce format, surtout n'hésitez pas
à les proposer dans les commentaires.
Et comme d'habitude,
si la vidéo vous a plu,
ne vous gênez pas, likez la et abonnez vous.
À très bientôt les épicurieuses et les épicurieux !